for
in women the breast is the most common
sight of cancer the incidence is higher
than that of all malignant neoplasms of
the reproductive organs combined in the
United States 68,000 new cases are
discovered annually there are 24,000
deaths from cancer to the breast yearly
one of the most striking facts in
medicine is that the salvage rate of
cancer to the breast has maintained a
plateau for the past several decades as
shown by the nearly straight line in
this graph while in other areas of
medicine there have been remarkable
advancements as indicated by the dipping
line showing a decrease in the death
rate from cancer of the uterus mography
is the radiographic expiration of the
breast it is a safe reliable and
aesthetically acceptable method of
diagnosis of breast diseases in their
early stages mamography requires no
special equipment and demands only
meticulous attention to radiographic
technique mamography is not new Salomon
of Germany in 1913 used x-rays to study
his breast specimen Stafford El war in
New York is credited with being the
first to to apply these procedures prly
in
1929 the born of Uruguay and gersen kin
of the United States have more recently
describ the
examination in the spring of
1956 I was asked to do mography at the
University of Texas MD Anderson Hospital
and tumor
Institute in Houston Texas published
techniques gave poor results in my hand
as a matter of fact after talking to a
number of the earlier workers in
mography I found that the procedure had
fallen into use due to the erratic
results obtained with poor quality
rogram a wide range of technical
factors was investigated prior to
adoption of our mographic technique
utilizing equipment in the average
radiology department having only one
variable that of Target skin distance
and delivering consistently highly
diagnostic
mamogram we suggest you master this B
basic technique do it for 100 or 1,000
cases then experiment when you are aware
of the of how much detail is being
sacrificed we shall not be concerned at
this time with minor variations of the
basic technique all such variations have
been tried and found
nonrewarding presently we are concerned
with emphasizing the need for Max Rog
graphic detail in mamography
diagnosis will be the subject of a
future
program technique is 90% of the
procedure with interpretive ability
10% hisorical evaluation as well as our
own experience Bears this
out a procedure previously tried and
discarded in our
institution immediately became
enthusiastically endorsed as a routine
procedure when the clinicians were
presented with a technique of excellent
detail the Sonic Quon is a film of good
detail and this requires proper coning
fine grain Emulsion low kilov voltage
High
milliamperage the technique utilizes
only one variable distance and this
compensates for the wide range and size
and density in the various breasts
the full examination requires three
views the cranial cat view the
medialateral view and axillary view
usually the first two views can be
included on the 5 by8 half of an 8x10
film with the help of our chief mography
technologist Mrs Evelyn O'Donnell and
our model we shall run through the
procedure of
mography detailed facts and factors of
the technique will be gladly supplied
upon request we also suggest that you
spend some time in at one of our
teaching centers or with an experienced
demographer to polish your
Technique a cylinder cator is necessary
to achieve good detail an adjustable
diaphragm type of cone is not adequate
and must be
replaced any added tube filtration must
be removed
thus the examination is done with the
use of only inherent tube
filtration most cones with adjustable
diaphragms have 1/2 to 1 mm equivalent
aluminum filter in the light localizer
thus requiring
removal fine grain Emulsion with
adequate contrast range must be used to
record detail of 1/10 mm size objects
studied by mamography
very very fine grain industrial types
have been found most suitable it is used
in a cardboard
holder the slight stiffness of the
cardboard as opposed to paperbacks makes
positioning easier with exclusion of
skin wrinkles and air
pockets the Kil voltage setting is one
which at 36 in with the proper coning
just allows penetration of the 15 mm
aluminum wedge and a setting up 300
milliamp at 6 seconds this kilov voltage
is in the neighborhood of
inspection of the rograms of the wedge
allows final adjustment of the kilov
voltage this will be your setting for
the cranial carded view simply increase
2 kvp for the medial lateral view if the
mamogram is too
light go up 2K kvp on your average
setting if too dark go down to kvp it is
a film effect and reproducibility which
is important not the exact kvp
used some minor minor modifications of
the
existing X-ray equipment may be
necessary to achieve the low kvp and
high masas necessary for instance a
bypass to the safety control switch or
additional Taps from an auto Transformer
to get the required low kilov
voltage it is suggested that you check
carefully your tube Heating and Cooling
chart and figure as though you're
getting full masas
delivered this will be a large safety
Factor as there is electron fog at
filament and full masas is not truly
delivered since the kvp lowest set the
kvp lowest possible and work up you may
even start with 3 second exposures to
make sure this does not totally blacken
your film and overload the tube we may
now proceed with positioning of the
patient it is of extreme
importance that the patient is reassured
and
relaxed she is seated comfortably at the
end of a table adjustable in height or
an adjust stool that may be used in
combination with a fix
table the film is placed flat on the
table the cardboard holder as you just
saw is elevated as high as comfort
commits with this Edge pressed against
the chest
wall with the breast placed on the
film half the film is protected by a
lead shield and will be used for the
cranial coded view of the other breast
and added sandbag uh add
stability relaxation and dropping of the
shoulder prevents it clavicle from
obscuring the base of the
breast the nipple must be exactly in
profile that is tangential to the X-ray
beam the extreme periphery of the breast
will not be included in the cranial
carded view this however is is of no
great concern as these areas will be
well projected on the medial lateral
view the identification
marker is placed face up on the axillary
portion of the film so it can be read
from above if this is always done the
breast can be identified not only as to
the Superior or lateral aspect but also
to the correct
breast the head is turn to the contr
lateral side the tube is in swung into
place as you note the cone will be close
to the patient's face the tube is then
raised or lowered until the beam covers
the the breast with margin of about 1
in some estimate of the required Target
film
distance May previously be
obtained by exposures of
rograms
or with the use of the filament glow of
this nonfiltered beam in the subdued
light the central
beam is directed to the midpoint of the
base of the breast and parallel to the
chest wall the more
energetic Central beam traverses the
thickest portion of the breast will fall
off toward the periphery of the breast a
homogeneous density on on the mamogram
is thus
produced if it is desired to study any
point of interest on the film more
fully the distance can be decreased for
more detail study of appropriate regions
of the
breath as demonstrated here the value of
the extension
cone is
apparent the extended
cone by improved
colation compensate for the increased
masas from the decreased Target film
distance as a further modification
compression can be used in practice it
is rarely found to be necessary and does
require additional
gadgetry this is a finished product note
The Irregular dense
in the breast just beneath the AA and
cancer to review the technical factors
for the cranial caad
view there is no added
filtration we must use proper coning 6C
exposure industrial fine grain type film
Emulsion cardboard holder 26 Kil
voltage 300 Ma and just sufficient
distance to cover the breast usually
ranging from 22 to 40
in the medialateral view provides the
second projection of the breath if one
view could be considered the most
important this would be it also
apparently it is technically more
difficult to master the patient is
recumbent with her arm relaxed is shown
her head on the
pillow the film is tucked snugly along
the chest wall with patient in the
posterior Bleak position a wooden block
is used to to support the film this
block is 3 in thick it is important to
eliminate skin fold this is best
accomplished by elevating the breast and
carefully placing the flexible cardboard
holder to follow snugly the chest wall
and lateral surface of the
breast the patient is then adjusted
toward the lateral position if necessary
while keeping the breast in good contact
with the film holder this ensures that
even a small breast is seen in
profile the breast should be supported
purely by the wooden block not suspended
from the chest wall with such support
and suspended respiration motion is of
no greater problem than in radiography
generally
the nipple as shown is in profile half
the film is mask and kept in position by
a lead shield and if necessary an added
sandbag the large breast may require an
entire 8 by1 in film the central
beam is directed to the base of the
breast a small portion of the rib cage
is included this ensures complete
coverage of the
breast the tube is positioned so that
the breast is projected on the film plus
a border of approximately 1 inch the
patient is relaxed and
comfortable if a pendulous opposite
breast interferes it should be retracted
but the retracting arm and fingers
should be comfortably placed not with
the elbow
elevated nor with the wrist and finger
strained pendulus breast require more
care in prevention of skin folds being
interposed between the breast and the
film fer now we
shall repeat the positioning of the
medial lateral
view so that we can emphasize these
several points
again it's already mentioned this is the
view that generally causes uh greatest
difficulty in
positioning as can be
seen the curved set is placed along the
chest wall patient moved into the
lateral position so the nipple is nearly
in
profile tube is then brought into
position the opposite breast is
retracted if
necessary
very gently
retracted identification marker is
placed on the axillary portion of the
film readable from
above cone down views may be
obtained to demonstrate questionable
areas to better
Advantage here again the extension type
cylinder cone is of great
value
you see extending the cone if you'll
note there are several markers on the
cone these may be conveniently placed
for estimation of the area to be
covered there is no significant
diagnostic difference in the normal
medial lateral view as compared with the
cranial
CAD however with only a single
view a cancer such as indicated by the
ays here could not be localized it was
not evident clinically a second view at
right angles is required for Quadrant
localization the only change in
technical factors for the medior lateral
view is an added two kvp or the setting
of 28
kvp no added filtration proper coning 6
seconds industrial type film cardboard
holder 28 KV 300 ma again the only
variable is the change of the target
film distance so that the breast is
properly included in the X-ray beam this
usually varies from 22 to 40 in as on
the cranial coded view respiration is
suspended during each
exposure the third view taken to
complete the mammographic study is the
axillary view the patient is
recumbent the entire 8 by10 film is
placed in
position with the controlateral forearm
and hand plac comfortably over the
abdomen the ipsilateral arm arm is at
right angles to the trunk with the elbow
FL abduction must not be more than 90°
further abduction causes the scap to be
superimposed over the
axilla nor should it be less than 90°
further adduction causes skin FES to be
superimposed over the
axilla the patient is then rolled into
approximately 30° oblique
position the the X-ray beam is centered
to a point approximately 5 cm below the
apex of the axilla with the 8 by 10 in
film centered to the central beam the
breast hangs freely the target film
distance is 40 in for the average
patient in the
obese increased penetration is achieved
by decreasing the distance to 30 in not
by increasing the kilov voltage with
this shorter distance the centering
point is just below the apex of the
axilla an identification
marker is placed as on the other
views on the rogram of the axilla can be
seen the ribs humal head muscular planes
of the axilla and the retr space the
breast may be distorted in appearance
since it is not
supported these technical factors arise
from the use of the lowest kvp possible
for penetration of the normal axillary
tissue they are no added filter proper
coning 3 and 1/2 seconds industrial type
film fine grain cardboard
holder 54 kvp 300 Ma and the average
patient to Target film distance is 40 in
and in the obese it is reduced to 30
in in the obese as noted the target film
distance is reduced to 30 in covering
less area as indicated in the mamogram
in the left of your screen this is in
comparison with the area covered by the
usual 40in distance mamogram on the
right of the
screen
with any new renographic procedure
dosage rates must be
established from the average exposure
during mography the skin receives with
back scatter 2.4 and 2.8 r as shown in
the cranial caught at in the medial
later views the total dosage to the
midpoint of the average breast for the
three exposures is 3.3
R this dose is considered
safe careful processing of the films is
required developing time of up to 8
minutes at 68° F with fixing time of 10
minutes or more are
necessary a hand magnifying lens is an
indispensable Aid in viewing the
mammograms the detail on the Rog GRS is
so fine the structures not appreciated
by the naked eye will be appreciated by
magnification with this lens certain
areas of the mamogram may require bright
light for optimal
viewing mamography is not to replace
physical examination or bobsy but with
good technique it is a highly accurate
procedure the most important single
aspect of mamography is renographic
detail
a couple of examples may serve to
illustrate the necessity of good
mammograms the first one shown
here with numerous Flex of calcification
in the re best seen in the region in
this area
a is of a patient who came in
complaining of pain in her opposite
breast these typical calcifications of
cancer were revealed on the by
mamography
in a clinically normal
breast this next patient is that of a
rather obese lady
who uh came into the institution with
vague breast complaints the the breast
were nor clinically normal however with
mamography we see in the upper portion
of the breast near it's based a 2 cm
definite
carcinoma our third p
patient it's one who had a clinically
suspicious nodule in their breast seen
in the central portion of the breast on
this
mamogram uh which was uh quite clearly
carcinoma by mamography
however in the superior and somewhat
anterior to this Mass was a half CM
irregular density a second carcinoma
within this breast not appreciated
clinically in the opposite breast there
was also a central small lesion
approximately 6 mm in
size this illustrates the value of
mamography in which we have a suspected
carcinoma in one breast we find a second
carcinoma in this breast and a third
carcinome in the same patient in the
opposite breast two clinically
unsuspected carcinomas in the one
patient this is Extreme value in
treatment
planning I would like to point out that
with mamography we have the opportunity
to find breast cancers earlier with
better prognosis hopefully to change
that plateau of survival referred to
earlier demography is nothing but
written geography based on well
established
principles one one good mamogram
surpasses dozens of poor
ones my suggestion is aimed to maintain
or improve mammographic detail not
attempt shortcuts that may detract from
that
detail as mamography will only find its
full value if others duplicate and use
it
e